hello everybody and welcome to the
shruts show pro super show you do that
this is the also I'm noticing one
already technical hiccup so let's not
worry about that what we need to do
actually is adjust the sport but this is
the show where so can you see it yet
the show where you guys can donate money
for the Earl Nance initiative and while
at the same time well at the same time
actually we better go look at bored huh
yep guess we'd better go look at a board
slow start to the show but we were very
prepared for keeping you guys just a
chance to get those donations in you can
see them on your screen so feel free to
do it I'll get there no we're getting
there
we're getting there time we're almost
there we're very professional don't I
swear you don't need that much on the
right because there's two of them right
well let's get to here let's get to here
so yeah do you get those donations in
check out the punishments it's also
interesting to know what kind of other
punishments you guys would like to see
inflicted on the bros yeah there are any
suggestions for those please do let us
know next time we had we had a thought
right before we went on maybe there'll
be a wheel you know maybe a spinning
wheel maybe maybe some interesting stuff
a wheel of doom perhaps maybe some
interesting stuff with some characters
that you guys may or may not know from
the Chess Club to get some regular
appearances so what is up rolls good
luck to us hopefully we are trying to
crush you so there is a punishment if we
do fail to win today and I'd hate to see
it happen because Isaac and I would both
have to come in for a four hour stream
on Monday no no losing we don't want to
do it no losing I'm here anyway so Isaac
poor guy was not even supposed to be
here next Monday we did have a challenge
a moment ago but now we don't so we will
take any rated challenge looking
probably for some three minute
no losing but so I really don't have
that much to lose I'm gonna be here a
lot to stream for four hours that's not
a big deal
ladybug if you want to play us let's put
the thing in here okay so I am challenge
click that link in the chat there and
come attack us first two ten wins so you
know on throw as many challenges us and
us as you want um and we'll see what
happens
so yeah last time we did win this is the
second ever installed it blows attendant
to punish you because if you guys win if
the stream wins you get four more hours
of schranz burrow action we'll have to
come back on Monday for a four-hour show
tomorrow today's Saturday so Monday is
actually two days away okay and we'll
come back onto on Monday and we'll do a
for our special show and Isaac will be
complaining the entire time cuz he was
not supposed to be there I wasn't even
supposed to be here I'll be complaining
the whole time because you know the sit
probably supposed to do stuff during
that four hours so you have like work to
do or something
we'll just complain yeah Monday usually
my big office day but so I'll just be
complaining and money no matter what
anyway we've got a first challenge wasp
let's go was crush all right wasp
replace a nice one to start with
homeboy oh yeah wasp I didn't look this
up today you know boy yeah just what to
do he's got some spicy thing knocked him
against you before yeah and he told
myself a guy get some wasp prep but I
didn't do it so this is what I lost the
pond fun go you took your pond dude
alright
it wasn't prepared for this one mister
wasp now thank goodness he didn't even
protect his own punch thank goodness you
just want to keep nice and on this is
high-level stuff here I wouldn't expect
this is high level I wouldn't expect you
to understand it's some level wouldn't
expect you to get it
I ruin a pun
I love when he puns [ __ ] you're
bonding Boop
that's my fun now I'm gonna trade off
this guy I know what you intend you
intend on somehow trying to check my
means you go here because maybe the
queen is going here let's trade no this
guy he's gonna take it maybe very
slightly missplay but anyway
the one point you were up upon yeah and
we got some random position so we're
just doing a little chess now now now
we're doing put some pixels hopefully
yeah push just the right pixels against
this guy good a winning record against a
seven and five against the st. Louis
chess club well I got to try to get us
back closer to an even score but yeah
just a reminder for everybody watching
all of the donations you can't hear the
music
how do you know there's music then how
do we yeah how do you know there's music
I do for it's this right yeah up this
yeah you can up that is that better
worse did I make any change whatsoever
probably with some amounts of change
whatsoever must've happened right be a
little sneaky here and I'm taking
ticking ticking the wasp he's on to make
like clever tactics it's probably not
it's right square for a queen I got
ideas big ideas
all right now we're good
hopefully that's the right level for the
music ladybug is really becoming a
regular on the shows so hopefully I get
to play ladybug today hello Motech my
queen boy so now this is a text but so
is this so we're gonna find out what
happens here it probably feels like
might be working out well I take this
getting risky getting risky cuz now he's
got it all defend it for now okay
alright everything's okay I'm just
panicking a little worried about this
move but didn't happen I think I was
still fine but I thought that was
slightly better try mate theory how you
doing some people are having fun out
there some people love the show and are
actively supporting us from the outside
Dennis knows that he wishes he could be
a part of it I think dennis plays the
guys out there that's about the firm
crazy guy out there why did you hire him
off the street again uh well it seemed
like a good idea at the time but we all
make managerial mistakes in life so
that's the hard part
and I mean I only made one it was a big
one dude I made a big mistake
way more for knocks how you doing what
is up
hello are narcs what is this where Mac
says the oh you glhf pledge what does
that mean that means you're some some
good guy that likes to donate to good
causes is that what it means I don't
mean
OOP alright starting to take control
here there's got to be a thing on our
channel right it's like that means they
isn't it gave us some a number of bits
or no no I don't know but he didn't he
did it you know that's something we
should really know tak to puns wow
that's not really clear though cuz he's
gonna take care I'm gonna take back nope
didn't happen then I don't really
understand so I'm gonna take over here
first I don't think you're a tall ship
meeting me seems I might wait here here
[Music]
yeah we're doing well you're doing great
good chance the time though hopefully we
don't get time sabotage hopefully
absolutely nothing so really we have to
move fast because literally any
challenge people can throw at us and
will cost us a lot of time just cook and
like basically make us lose in this
position so I think we need to play
really really fast in general yeah just
in case like what we had to go do
push-ups what if we had to switch bros
like literally anything we would run out
of time
[Music]
I'm gonna play some random moves here
win on time the usual the classic all
right thank you
wasp so that puts us up oops made that
wrong button every single time did you
see no transfer stream an excellent
start for the Schwartz's we are on the
board might win yet again is this how
many weeks in a row just go down two
weeks in a row mate theory oh we got
spider moves in there
we got spider moves in there you've got
some Oh some people might be trying to
crush us today I'm gonna have you're the
crusher you do the crowd will play
anybody so spider moves in the queue all
right who that wasn't the usual idea
normally people have been starting to
play this queen of three nonsense
against me I don't get it but now what
we see here
interesting don't give me that Bishop
the bishops development is so good II
wanted to develop it twice
[Music]
just keep this guy here a little sneak a
little sneak back that way they never
see it when it pounces later don't know
if it was in front you'd be I'll see it
you find a piece and you know it's there
man imagine a chess but with fog of war
you can only see the piece that's like
closest to us
oh yeah we got to explore other options
I wonder if there's a way to put stuff
on the screen so it actually affect us
while we're playing yeah yeah you would
be able to see yeah some of their pieces
or something yeah
you are interested in a very kind trade
offer you all support this and then put
this guy somewhere yeah just kind of a
normal equal position so we'll make some
random moves and hopefully out speed
this person and I guess hopes it no
horrible challenges pop out and attack
us in the middle of all this you know
what looks dumb 400 420 push-ups so
Teddy H no you'll wait and see just you
wait and see how we do it it is a - bro
well challenge I mean it's ten it takes
two it takes two bros but one bro does
20 ok ok ok does take two bros one one
to adjust the camera angle one to do the
whoever's playing will actually run over
here
so your job if they get the push-ups
camera you got to run there cuz you
gotta take you longer to set that up the
media musician I'm gonna be ready
gotta get yeah I always love that when
you have a night that's in front and I
could defend something behind it
let's just always fun it's the best way
to push up off my night now Oh what have
I done to my for night I think I'm
losing now yeah what can you do
sometimes you're losing don't tell him
don't tell him don't tell him don't tell
him nobody tell him so chance to see you
on YouTube this could go on YouTube I
don't know we'll see how it goes
and hopefully dude meet there he takes
me down I'll just say no banned from
YouTube don't let the people know you
down it never happened can let people
know but now there's a serious chance
like the show goes well it could end up
on YouTube so hi YouTube in the future
how you guys doing it hope you enjoy
this content come watch us on Twitch
some time so you can punish the bros and
crush us like meat theory here
well what can you do all right all we
can do now I'm also gonna shop for
Bishop it's your turn pawn got to do it
for me
oMG YouTube that was much better
well all of our tournament stuffs still
gonna be on YouTube I think right yes
you will be able to watch the commentary
for the candidates coming up on YouTube
shows like that will still be on YouTube
things like the classic and the norm
tournaments those kinds of tournaments
will still be on YouTube pro chess
League still be on YouTube stay tuned
check our schedule as things change
push but yeah our goal here is to grow
our twitch channel
okay we can't be in there dude think I'm
have a good chance just be in there so
clean doing a good job on this diagonal
don't see a threat I have a threat queen
doing an awesome job on this diagonal
I'm almost strong enough only some sort
of weird challenge could slow me down
take away a victory here I might have
this one against make theory well done
awesome well done us drugs team trances
best right two to nothing easy day
easy day nothing could get in my way
not even spider moves well so that's a
load of Toby's probably nothing tougher
than this let's go let's go spider can
you be the first Pat's are opening look
at this check get checked - look at this
move oh but you should be three secret
prep hope you weren't ready for that one
secret yeah how was your night gonna go
wasn't yet threatening b5 I think that's
still a little I look this up again wow
this one what's going on fun what what
are you done here is this real you have
a trick with chicken coop
[Music]
which upon go
what are you doing buddy
we're ready to see the famous Shantz
technique never fails is the never
failing Sean's technique comment right
up smooth as butter
alright fine got your pawn back you know
what
[Music]
what's different rook the rook singing
what you just take that rook wait what
sir excuse me what's happening excuse me
why well in the world
what was that excuse me oh wow
take that take that chaunce is too
strong tonight that rematch
you guys better Swiss roll out ever had
better switches bro out hey get in here
everyone's coming to celebrate the big
victory come here look at this we got
come here dude on stream look at this an
easy win you want to see how 227 right
here - everybody could watch France pros
crushing everybody today
that move from laughing a little
suspicious
you guys better pay a hundred bits and
switch this bro out so what we're doing
here just so you can see I see it's
easiest for us to see it up there this
is the Front's bro Super Show or joint
special guest Darius weirds Grandmaster
and so looks like they can pay so we're
three to nothing if they get vergis ten
points if we get ten points we don't
have to do anything if they get 10
points the stream they beat us then we
had we had no punishment so on Monday
we're gonna have to do a four-hour
stream just a special bonus punishment
stream his day off he's gonna have to
come in so they can pay us [ __ ] they in
face sub-second paid bits and so far we
haven't had any challenges so today's
been smooth but I'm just telling you I
just don't bits you better switch these
bros out I'm gonna be crushing everyone
no do I do anything but that one skip
the three to anything 100 else student
any sight I implore you I'm Way too
strong do you want it you want to see it
wait no good so yeah we'll need to catch
up with you
sometime after this show but yeah we got
what like an hour left
oh wow yeah just pulling in 20 keep it
nice and simple it just began we got
that's odd this one alright make a small
threat capture take this doing great
today I'm on fire
no but because yeah I know yeah boy
though so it's gonna play g6 trap me but
it's gonna take this guy it's not a big
deal I think oh alright
you heard it here first Bishop's are
better than pawns but they but they look
just like pawns but bigger okay take my
pawn you did it I'm out getting out here
run away yeah brave Sir Robin no helpers
we get all the help we need you guys get
to do all the punishing so I'm sure
there's enough punishments that even
take this nope don't want to lose a
queen I almost did it I almost gave him
a queen away I'm not quite losing a
queen yeah well not at all either but I
don't know making it so interesting hmm
I'm good okay
the safest night to put here the safest
I put here slightly I mean this
beautiful c5 is like big bomb because
like it's running exactly just a big
fancy pawn that's my claim Dudek policy
five pawns bishop same value man just
yeah okay and yellow shirt go away why
don't you guys you guys can probably
inflict so much punishment that it
wouldn't matter who is sitting next to
me you know going for this guy I'm not
take it probably can't take them
mm keep wanting to blunder a night by
playing here so keep doing it protecting
winning go here get rid of this Queen
here from the Queen trade take that pawn
a bunch bunch of knights and rooks
that's good
yep that was the plan just clean out of
here wall adding an attacker nice close
don't let this thing get out of control
you'll be doing well here that's good
and I've been playing well so Wow no
hesitation your tricky stuff
[Music]
quite see how to make things work here
doesn't look good for who we don't he's
got LightSquared bishop dude if you
never move your rug able to take this
thing somehow you're fun to call if the
plan to take that thing here we are just
Manning up and taking it you're not
gonna take it right now but if you
switch bros that might be a more there's
a likely of them to either free yeah
let's go for that I like it this poem
because maybe I'm going here I'm going
here if I ever get checked I can block
pretty much yes they put it just gonna
here right away let's just keep this
file on lockdown I'll sign you through
that yeah I will do that that looks
pretty good I'm evil who's so dropping
all the material very soon yeah honestly
I wouldn't be too here's oh I'm here
didn't know what else to do is let me
respond lets it could it could be
interesting for 400 bits so we went out
to do push ups imagine like I have to
run
like pretty much any little obstacle
will make it very difficult to actually
win even if we're super winning take one
okay taking anything I did see it if you
insist
I didn't see it I would have if I saw it
lose it
there's no way you're taking the
suggestion for me yeah it's just the
general principle
arrey arrey too strong game too strong
and be stopped I don't think the thing I
think it's gonna be the easiest this
might be it I think I'm to adopt a team
- that's too quick thank the Senate
there's no messing around
all right stupid Nick oh this is the guy
I beat five minute game though oh we won
yeah I won this okay so the switching
bros might not be enough here even
switching the bros here might not be
enough to give nicknames here real
challenge guess Isaac it's already
taking you down so that bodes well for
me got our inaugural victory against
stupid nicknames instrument Oh aftering
them zone in progress you've made a
youtube video about this I don't think
so I know you made it about an f3
something into three thank ou Bank oh
yeah as a recent one well that's on a
secret Channel we're not gonna win [ __ ]
but I hear it's mighty like I keep
leaving organic comments on it
you've seen this help I was gonna say
this is a different pawn structure now
it's gonna ask if you've seen this game
bought in a Captain Lanka but it's not
one structure anymore free hmm yeah
based on his response I believe he has
seen that game boy I don't see that
check might be good might be good why
not so huh all right pretty interesting
enough to oh yeah
which is a punishment I didn't have to
but if yes what is it that's 300 meters
I'll play f3 and king of 2 or f6 King f7
on my first two moves of the next game
so that could be an interesting way to
spice it up you know we've also it just
go for a key set like yeah I'm gonna
start with this focus Aramis what's he
doing
you crashing through that Center there
but oka never it moves like this
so now though it's interesting because
there's a pin it's very interesting
don't you maybe see a better move but
I'm just playing this because I'm
thinking to check how this actually
actually might be pretty pet don't you
have taken the night
yeah check oh no a Koleos check but it's
still good it's still good yeah it goes
here didn't do it ah it's my date I
didn't see that looks good alright well
done please don't beat me
I also gotta remember this is a much
longer game this one so I can't just
rely on all my quick cheap moves to pay
off for me
might have to I look like I might have
to play a couple good moves
she's not my specialty that's weird who
does that it's not my specialty it's
really not my style
I'll check my check with it usually wait
Oh actually yeah might be in a bit of
trouble might be in a bit of trouble
things are certainly the spice factor
has kicked it up a notch air coming into
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
switchblade somebody else gonna go a
suspect how's the carton real blind you
might have been the better bro for this
task
oh boy right some viewers know not too
happy not too happy
be honest way to do it
crying workers are going up to it it
really really displeased here no I can't
do anything it was a knife from a
pentecostal hey kiddos thinking of
cooking you want boy this is also a sort
of falling apart move
in the house of cards comes crumbling
down why are you playing so good
it's not fair to play this good because
yank I got them all revved up yesterday
man
are you ruined for mate and I think we
know I think we know no some people have
this like why would people want to
punish you ladybugs
we got a ladybug in the chat like what
dude I'm not gonna a little paint but I
want you to winner block with your night
block for the night what looking takes
with a pond you check mail question it's
a nice nice try you have a clean edge
tool I mean if we get made it we're
gonna make this all right here we go Oh
what's happening I have to resign if
that finds Ellen yeah it looks like a
resigner
I was doing so well I was doing so well
until you weren't ah
you're doing great until you were doing
bad I could what nicknames well done
good one taking the chair so bad that
there's one like right there okay go
good chef you didn't you a chair oh we
had a challenge when he disappeared all
right who wants some you know we got our
first defeat going so it was very smooth
and we got crushed nicknames really took
us down nobody's here let's check this
one out guys waiting for our challenge
to come in very well played game by Sir
nicknames absolutely let's check it out
what went wrong so yeah first surprise
here
i takes main move I guess people play
Bishop d2 here make some sense what so
c4 mixes c4 I'm gonna come back probably
off the stream we got some more
challenges casual not gonna get it done
five minutes
fine fine if you're the only one in the
queue we'll accept a 5 my success really
has been that people have been
challenging to three-minute games and
then I don't have to play so well just
play faster mm-hmm does not blunder
faster not a Sicilian player but in the
presence of a mighty Grand Master I
didn't want to play the French you know
he might judge me I know that's what
they all say you know they all say it no
you see what we can do here
get back some way randomly in that
direction that's why I need to be a
3-minute game I got to take back with
some something then move on to the next
decision and what did the game wouldn't
be long enough consequences to man of us
[Music]
at night who knows where the night goes
down to literally any square so we'll
put him on a random one get some random
loose if tonight the checkmated before
coming then I guess this is Benji for in
96 he wants to be the type
yes
working with affordable
this works still tempted to do it that
well fortunately been made it there it
made it no you will not get made it
because like I was mean but you find out
if say some right now
so take someone throw this it was my
idea shouldn't take care things off I'm
fine
and you know you can listen to me
alright we got more celebrities in the
house
hello or 11 in memoriam the house
no she doesn't work today whoa
awkward why did you say she's coming if
she said she's coming about yes you need
to set up for your stream and you're
doing it in Turkish and you want to do
it in here well during the Super Show
are you gonna do it out there somewhere
okay do you enjoy set up in the other
studio I guess you can do it in there or
you can do it in here you want to come
in here we got a party in here you have
an agreement then yeah then I guess you
should do it you should do it in the
other studio and then just come in here
right whenever you're done sweet cool hi
sweet so yeah that is Niger who you can
go watch he'll be doing some Turkish
commentary she'll be on the front page
twitch like whatever the turkey
variation is now how do I not get
checkmate it anybody have any ideas
great stuff
okay let's gonna bring my queen back but
I like bring the rook back between here
what is this little Ridge so yeah same
deal trade these Queens
how bad oh this one didn't see it coming
never kind of seen it win this we're
getting time 55 57 just for sure mate so
lots of ideas lots of ideas just smash a
bit not this week's been easier though
in the sense that they just talked
face-first into not quite check me well
you win the you Queen check and then
come back and take the bishop with the
clean free bishop
follow me a clean Chuck and then what
what do I come back I thought he was
gonna I thought he had the block you can
run away then I'm done I don't know not
as easy also it's here elope look a move
I thought I could check I don't know
it's a big bum see what I can do there
yeah I will take this queen he's gonna
get another one what's a big problem for
me all right little problem where's the
king wanna go hey you gotta go this way
right oh that way that's way up there -
also I don't know this one should be
check there we'll just start here and
I'll check any good
so this check let's check might be good
it's really big to check let's try that
one over a king we go here village goes
back to the dark square the other checks
[Music]
I'm on here you have my Bishop if you
want position huh
think okay so better
that's so where's the chat where's the
challenges maybe they've been secretly
coming in maybe this isn't updating
where you guys at come on are you guys
just so enthralled by the games here in
Drupal nicolas geek dory
[Music]
now show off my technique my famous
endgame technique you're famous for it
[Music]
in their book King get more over here
rook take all these things really go one
time look how good he is
I was doing great just being shielded
though we'll attempt not to get
checkmated here see I know this guy he's
gonna try to check maybe super easy
on it's too good on it's too good yeah
oh it's too good
[Music]
fons - good they're all pretty good try
it one more time
dang it's still not working all right
you can only go that way where you
looking checked ruthlessly yeah you
could go guys
your ankle jaw hit what Bistro oh yeah
we're late well I got this
I had he has another deal he's bringing
the other and the other pawn I'd bring
it to me let's go bring me that phone
okay yeah ask and you shall receive
believe if you had a point can't believe
it was a point cannot believe it
guy had a point you had a me at a point
think I can survive this for 40 seconds
no I think I should resign in
humiliation yes humiliated I got
humiliated
now things are going so well yes oh look
at that face
Wow got some tough people here so let's
keep it up with a tough guys before the
Barossa which may or may not happen I
know it hasn't looked like it we're
playing the French okay I'm staying true
to myself
we weren't goofing around gotta stay
true everybody likes it exchanging
everybody likes to exchange the PSS
we're all big fans exchanging
cases some work we deserve it impossible
yeah that's the plan alright thank you
for the game that were you was you in
f6f-5 well people don't know about this
position is it's all about the center
that's what people don't know it may
look like big opposite side castling but
[Music]
No
score should be up there says sports to
top right so no punishments issued yet
so so far so good for us do you guys do
want to support the Nance Elementary
initiative so that they can get a chess
program in their school please donate
during this show and you might even get
four more hours of trances if we somehow
lose this show you might get that on
Monday as our big punishment if you guys
somehow take us down
right now we're crushing you guys four
to two
seems hopeless you know don't give up
hope guys few donations you might be
able to win our game maybe you want
surrender ha ha move
several bishops for now a long time to
come
you still have more background this guy
has a square yeah that's pretty good
this night has a square all my pieces
have squares now
is there anything we not taking my
nephews of it yeah
because I was doing good yeah saw this
night coming here you got a little
scared
so I just took them I got the file it's
all going my way
pressure here worst case I can go here
we know we'll just take a little ink
come back come back for seconds also
threatening it this is what this was 3-0
so you have no chance if you do
challenge me 3-0 just know you have no
chance beat at 2,700 crush them couldn't
handle the time to take care you're
gonna get that pawn but I get two pawns
so ya figure if you go here I get a
so-so
yeah should be good hey Shrek how's it
going I'm gonna move something just you
know I do have a plan to move something
well this guy all right
what everyone
okay let's hop around random night
hopping usually is the key to finding
Forks usually you just you just keep
going going until you're just kind of
miracle job well they're all on the same
color wait I recognize that pattern if
this money really will go to sport chest
I'm with you it really does so it's yes
it's really helpful every single
donation is huge 100's which bro switch
bro you gotta go that way
yeah go that way go that way where did
you go so far you gotta go that way you
go that way oh this is the gimmick it's
a rotate you follow then we crash into
each other all right you got this way up
on time up upon everything's going well
but there was a bro switch so thank you
go Strix big hero go Strix so but
imagine if people just kept doing that
like hundred bits letters all the time
hundred bits would lose so many game
yeah ya know thank you very much go stop
it
mmm let me out ahh go tricks I apologize
it's definitely not ghosts
on attack another pond attacked my oh my
text detector work in the night with
your king cool
if the pond you can still go there you
go well done alright in our favor we got
the slow bro in there okay give me 2000
[Music]
those are some well with some well time
point I was so sick well this is a delay
I thought you're gonna make it in time I
thought you had the time because right
because that has that delay so how close
was it
it must've been really close as I
started it I started at 20 SEC yeah yeah
there's no I was like I have to do a
push-up every half second yes of course
get strong dude yeah I'm just not that
strong
okay you guys got it
you guys got that one you guys made me
exercise today
look the heck so right that's perfect I
mean one of the me2 check it can be
three plus two smart smart in case the
push-ups come three plus two well I got
all the tough guys too so maybe you've
got easier you've got all those like hi
I'm the low to mid-range people who's a
new name I didn't know a farmer Kip
thank you very much farmer so alright
this is professional just some
high-level chess being played now that
will get a big bro switch you're really
good at this game
yeah so far so good you told me Magnus
did this I mean again okay I believe it
he finished before the clock ran out
yeah it was close just barely it was
close so your high-level counsel very
professional chess player mm-hmm always
always trade always castle that was
exhausting running to that camera I got
it yeah that must have been a lot of
work I'm sure your is that least five
feet away just worn out just absolutely
talker it out all right well I've moved
all my stuff what do you know
yeah perfect random moves but I moved
all my stuff what are you a grandmaster
come up with the appropriate plan select
from a large group of plans that you've
mastered or play like us just random
moves the don't blow into pieces in one
move
okay that's it yeah you're you can't
you're speaking gibberish to me for a
second there I was it if you can't go
over a long list of known plans and pick
the best one based on Royston
what are these bro such switch this is
so weird
just one time what are you doing I don't
understand what you want me to do there
you have a limited time to her an
exclusive emotes what's the hype train
whoa all aboard the hype train guys I
know my gosh what happened like I'm so
I'm 1900 and you're 40-something
yeah all right that's all right I mean
maybe I'm like my my rating never caught
up to my playing strength so it's hard
to really get laid official I did a lot
more studying than I did
actually I trained going there's a hype
train you guys know about it people keep
donating you'll build up the train and
everybody will get more reward let's
just say Jonathan's like 400 500 points
stronger than me and all weddings the
USDF blitz is like 2,000 on this website
I'm like a high 2,300 right off I look
like queen takes that night there's a
pin that night your thought in this
position you know what do I do it can't
do it
I'll try removal much harder still clean
pure it's a bad move now I still want to
try to pretty move it just to see mm
leech ass is probably like seventeen to
eighteen hundred USA off classical ish I
mean on average obviously some people
are better or worse my class golden
blitz
both could be dumb but it's your one
time here it's just pretty hard to
compare with ratings and like separate
pools they're just having a look at the
situation here 1600 he has to think
every move you guys shouldn't be less
than a second yeah exactly
done yeah yeah yeah so I have to keep
like a minute on the clock just to just
in case any nasties come my way
do we play variance wasn't planning on
it it could be is that somebody is it GM
somebody yeah that Gianluca camera it's
the real guy
well but that's i JH I do know it so
it's a fake impostor
also really hoping really hoping now he
found it I found it my random moves fast
random moves faster and it moves fast
let's go let's go let's go let's go
let's go
no I didn't think that was gonna happen
random moves faster faster faster
somebody donated in the head to sack
[Music]
sure yeah come on Texas Queen it wasn't
on the screen I guess I guess you guys
didn't see it but I had to I had to Sag
all this stuff there okay that's really
unfortunate that that happened to you
man yours really got you good bad bomber
guys leave us alone you know I'm just
trying to play the game you guys are
stuffing all the time
stout good sometimes might as well do it
now cuz I got a few more pieces like it
oh my
that still sort of sensible because I
have all that many useful pieces anymore
no random moves you know chess is really
hard to play with your this behind so
it's just so hard at this play melodic
Stapley - no no I have no idea
oh that changes my strategy entirely
that's not very cheated Isaac why did
you take took the next one down the list
man dude I'm fine a three plus two I
wasn't gonna rely on flagging I was just
gonna win the game you took my one trick
away from me and I'm gonna lose to a
sixteen under something I was playing a
very professional game you saw the game
I was playing very professional well my
pieces and cast you know about that I go
they resigned what I just didn't ah
guess it just wasn't like catching us
man oh gosh we have the stream on Monday
for Florida we're gonna stream on Monday
I have fatigue so we played Nick me I'm
gonna need some casual stations and it's
also unlimited tricky five minutes I'm
gonna go to three minutes first even if
we got a plane on it tough guy this is a
tough guy so let's go pipe train is long
gone better luck next time
I've trained out of the station six and
a half six and a half that's our big
record I don't like this one
hello Matt the other stuff this is weird
well in my mind Castle kingside
life I had a very limited idea anyway
support was happening then you got
something said to make sure I've lived
[Music]
trate trate you know I have a tendency
to love a good trade Joran you are a bit
of a traitor oh I'm a notorious traitor
people know my love for training was
this an issue no I take it ok good job
me double-checking we do them eject
before you made the move - that was the
real kick it's fine for me it's great -
even nice and fast also I remember good
player here been known to trade once or
twice in my life I don't want my
reputation to be damaged so no bye nope
Oh Peter sees it ah now we win we win
our minor celebrities more celebrities
in the house the day full of surprises
the pan would wow he's scattered his
handle the limelight you know not every
star was meant to shine bright he is out
of here I said somebody else's one I
stay hydrated I knew there'd be running
involved
but this but then not so it went
[Music]
oops Oh check what a trick this trick
I thought was good little trick found
the way out of that one weasel you go
for my guys I'll go for your guys so
we'll see what happens
I think rook stick bombs a little bit
faster tonight's do mm-hmm
he left it was for else yeah people have
been giving ladybug it's been a
challenge you know about one guy was
very unfortunate one game was just
pretty maybe maybe one game we got
outplayed maybe maybe one time in the
history of chess we got our play other
than that but it's been one sabotage
really got us who dares beat us people
that care about Nance I guess people
that want to see the kids get a program
in their school been donated we were
defeated by general trading today I have
a history and a reputation to protect
so I have to trade here go pon go Pongo
array we finally finally there yeah it
was four to nothing stream tied it up
Frances bouncing back
alright retaliation time here's our time
to shine let's see well some brush um
three two and we'll look the three triki
triki made a good decision switching it
back to a three minute game so I will go
there wait who's this crazy rope switch
broke I played before cuz I know you
I literally haven't played before
my bad well now you got this position
that's a good move though
oh god no there's this guy Bobby Fischer
grizzly what do we first off Gambon I
missed your chance is that what the
people play here yeah the great know
you're professional this looks this is
like mangas verse popping right now you
don't
usually doesn't work when they can
cancel I don't know I don't play it dude
that's okay it's fine I'd respond to it
sometimes from the other side hmm before
is known to win upon what mine is that
I'd like to sell it to all the pros in
the world if you can tell me which line
wins upon by force
thanks you again go tricks Yeah right
yeah is it was it a good decision should
he have done it right at the start of
the game should he do it with like ten
seconds left
choose wisely choose wisely oh this is
great so now he also gave the push-ups
before so he does push-ups again it's
you okay that's the best part about this
chair it's not the chess
it's the now I having to do the push-ups
you can check me though I'm sure do it
go check rhythm yeah easy
just keep keep pushing those pixels
until until this one is red or not well
that one that one turns right yep I'm
pushing this I check me one two three
checkmate oh yes mr. Noah
that's super easy yeah go for it oh yeah
okay I was thinking about it those
bishops yeah you slightly yeah you
slightly lost the bishop I kind of lost
the bishop those are really easy
beautiful deep sacrificial idea but like
you have to play like a for now right
he's on the B to pawn so you gotta be
careful he's on the b2 we do want to
check me cuz we did give up the
thingamabob right
oh wait yep no big deal opening the F
file catastrophic mistake oh look at
that open up but I got a rook on it now
sure you're done done for it's done for
it I'll look on the bright side when
things get sima hopeless in life Oh God
and look on the bright side are really
bad all right
all things have gone I'm gonna say
downhill I'm gonna say down trying to
play four tricks like Queen H to work f6
hit hoping mostly hoping I don't think
it does anything all right it's
Grandmaster proved it means it's a good
idea to Queen h2 idea rook f6
nope and then what if though I take this
yeah I'm just not taking that yeah thank
right it's not responding to that so he
takes you bishop you take back with a
king and then yeah what you gonna do
what you gonna do tricky this might be
too tricky for you Oh didn't optimize
their clock losing time to switch bro
and 10 seconds later good push-ups yeah
there tag-teaming their push-ups might
be enough 49 so go fast go fast go fast
they got it in their mind they got it in
their mind to take the finish up your
threat is to take the bishop yeah tricky
you'll be lucky if somebody doughnuts
you'll be so lucky to steal an own you
better be fast this time okay checking
again Kingston run around and means to
reduce checking this probably mate
probably mate mate Mon Wow tricky bow
how you like those tactics area or again
dare you open the F file tricky how dare
you wow that guy that got spicy rook F
6x6 in your face in your face too tricky
for you says Bishop stars good game good
vision we did nicknames haven't done
unit or not I got it I have to tell guys
for alright yeah you do the little guys
I'll take care of the top guys oh yeah I
gotta make sure to give us our points
yeah we deserve it six to four baby will
not be seeing you guys on Monday that's
the way it looks it's like we will not
be here on Monday
all right you hold there's about five
immediately kept your shirt smell
actually really windy tree can you play
good you can have it so
[Music]
I'm gonna have to establish rules about
what we're allowed to say to the other
bro because being we've been different
and they're not then a girl commentary
true maybe we need a mute bro no okay
but come on I saw suck Queen h2 rig
after sex I had to mention it literally
like I'm not gonna be able to sit there
quietly
[Music]
okay you don't like it yeah that's a
first
okay Pond singing what's he write a pond
so you can trade nights to take the
planet if you want it it's possible oh I
have no no he's got fun hanging Neath
the guy in the yellow shirt who you
Daniel is it he's he's been cooperating
he hasn't been
most geum's come in here and they watch
for a minute they're like I can't even
watch this we do appreciate you sticking
with us
ya know but yeah not a penny
yeah go ahead I dare you to take that
pawn girl we will never ever in our life
get back rank checkmated that's not in
the Shantz blood
we never get back rank made it don't I
don't know yet Oh tricky move I don't is
tricky whose sole things
Samina izumi-kun he could defend
backwards I see free weights are so good
at this turnout they must be really
lucky yeah they're just really lucky
it's no way it's hard work I'll get good
you know what happened after f3 so we'll
just take it I think uh my losing my
night no no way I'm not no way
what are you worried about rook c1 I
like a [ __ ] worried about rook see one
oh no oh no six Cillian not rook c1 I
was oh no oh no the night AHA gotcha
gotcha
it was got'em until Adam got to use the
stream tactic so until the sarcasm that
thanks Aditya I appreciate it update all
right I know I'm actually contributing
to victory here all right food game six
iliyan all right what's the next person
I haven't played here a 300 fan all
right it must be upset
all right Bebo fan the e ball fans are
upset right now because you have this
season it's gonna be like two months
delayed are we doing rated yeah we're
looking for rated I'm gonna go it's got
to be written in order of preference 305
of three two okay I didn't know if you'd
have a different didn't know if you'd
like my ligaments
I like 500 way more than three too
personally okay that's good no thank you
please play the English opening I don't
know opening side I can't
sure clip hundred bits suit yourself
push-ups oh my gosh oh oh it's okay two
three four five six seven eight nine 10
11 12 13 14 15 16 17 18 you got it
what a play chess all right all right
push-ups are on a 3 minute cooldown oh
gosh what move was even played last
session switch all right we're switching
be both in here I didn't pay any
attention to what happens so far but I'm
sure this is fine whoa nice try guys oh
you guys you make that a sec you not
thought you'd get us wear him out and
then give him a break good job guys the
other good job all right
you removing this guy's probably in
there thanks farmer I'm glad you had
already cleaning on the business right
you tell me which piece to move okay
so that's what I did you're welcome well
you had to do 20 push-ups then run
around the table twice you know way to
sack my queen
just clean g4 let's go or they'll see
what he does whatever he does okay
like queen g4 or something try to get a
knight for it before all right let's go
all right hi thanks farmer that one
might be too much to come back from
we'll find out yes it's good for us but
it's a moral victory
not good yeah as long as we get that
night back everything fine nor no vision
and I'm coming on bond thinks gonna take
more than that do you think more than
push-ups and Toubro switches and a sub
you know
let's go focus though we need to win
this one come on this is like the most
they've done to us
so we got a win just to show them
nothing could take us down just others
no for all the noise down only a strong
rope in action okay just get get out of
Jason yeah good good good good good good
good good safe see all the tricks get
out of the tricks train in the Schrager
create trade trade trade runs in the
family
chances are known traders just be
careful be careful to not repeat one
just not repeat one just anything or
anyone like that no cuz there's a check
yeah but kinky sweet
wait that works right oh yeah yeah sure
looks like that works
oh you're sure sure sure sure holy cow
just complain or ketu like an idiot so
good one you just stood find you've just
been studying the Machuca rock too much
oh I have yeah come at us again guys
dang it alright
and some stock tricks best all right
well he doesn't see it either so don't
worry about it wow that's almost you're
forced to see it at some point you know
I mean I just can't get ping feel it
you're gonna get then dude maybe not to
do this one's just gonna win we're done
nice nice nice
[Music]
brief moments of rest bite really art
it's like actually the most I need
exercise ever for the sake of the show
you know the kids what's the position
what's happening ah you got a passport
honey I'm gonna win I'm gonna win I'm
gonna win I'm gonna win I'm gonna win
this is easy this is so easy such an
easy win
such an easy win there's warrior king
where your king or your king oh my gosh
it's a crazy pre move cute I wasn't
paying much attention to his happening
there that previous still super easy to
invest SSS
[Music]
at all easy with baby so you can kill us
Wow nothing can kill the Schwartz's
we're too strong for anything you can
throw at us maybe for more than that in
everybody's face egg take that all over
all of your faces stuff that was SS
brought it and we rose to the challenge
I only see one for a minute game all
right I know the old in the air but I've
all of a sudden I've warmed up I'm not
sure why beer drinker I'm not exactly
sure what happened uh-oh oh we played a
bad move what can we do about it here
you go I don't know how it happened it
just came out naturally it just came out
I don't know how it happens that was lot
of fun the only good one so go check are
you pretty funny alright that doesn't
work so yeah probably
he is your new one castle
now take it easy guys just for her feel
free
take it easy and you know like oh I used
to be athletic stick one game now like
60 push-ups in half an hour used to not
be a daunting task what was I doing here
Who am I I'm gonna get you here I come
you're coming to get me though I don't
how to do this so you might be faster
probably I need to not back down
you know overtreat help you no retreat
so don't back down and then you play
back down back I'm going forward
whoa didn't see I'm coming
maybe he didn't see I could take out the
Queen yeah baby that's a sack no that's
not a sec all I can stack is my queen to
the rock for the rook yeah I know but
that's that's literally only sick right
I think the rook sec oh no it is the
queen second one says it's a queen sec
alright well now we got an issue now we
have issues just could backfire oh sure
we should definitely set that alert to
be higher up on the priority list
but it's on top of all the other stuff
yeah boy thank you for the sub mega
Blaziken oh oh you're done dude when I
toast
take my buns hos take it okay care about
nothing I don't care about nothing
nothing never takes the schwanz is down
we are way too strong for this game I
can't handle this
I used to play tournaments but then feed
egg bands me said it was too strong
really unfortunately feeder to do that
to you I said yeah I didn't wanna play
in this easy League anyway
good one this might be insurmountable
this looks doesn't feel easy here
doesn't feel easy I'm a bit squeamish
for you stop with all the trading that's
my ideal so I'm known for this is all
right well thank you for stopping by
it's been fun we'll see you later yeah
well we'll be there for another I don't
know how many we're here for won't be
long now we just got two more games we
have two more games don't you
whatever you're good yeah thanks for
stopping by thank you guys see ya
how many piss you get the guy in the
yellow shirt to play uh how many bits oh
you gotta come back too many bits too
many you don't have enough money answers
three three three answer someone's
asking if they could donate enough bits
to get you to play but yep the answer is
yes you gotta do it for the school
comeback
yeah yeah for three three three right
now it's got to be right now three three
three will do the old GM switch in you
might even be able to help this position
[Laughter]
it's gotta be right now he's bought he's
out the door he's walking doors closing
it's got to be now three three three is
your magic number just a high-pressure
salesman got it take care about the kid
you should go work at a car dealership
alright five seconds right five four
three two one all right I think you say
all right all right deal off table to a
lot of people's delight I was hoping she
could come in here and ask you this yeah
him I got no chance here do I
Oh what's happening
Oh Oh beer drinker you have too many did
you have a little bit too many to drink
here not easy for me still not easy at
all blowing up on
absolutely crazy you gotta be so careful
here please no airport here still no no
at the time the time the time the time
the time yeah not gonna happen here not
gonna happen here dang it oh ah not for
sure you take with the bishop what dang
it I had a good position if I took the
time though the time I have no time
actually could've had a big comeback
there anything goes anyway you miss
there's a big fun about discuss which
bad timing for it real casual about this
one ah hurry hurry
oh my god seconds stranger things
stranger things yeah boy so we could you
know you remember you beat me nope
I honestly have no recollection of it I
tend to drown these things out but yeah
I'll remember it stop it now goes for
hundred bits oh yeah
stop with the push-ups no dude alright
update it they got it they got one they
got one no they didn't know I didn't see
it yeah it's funny if I even just waited
what stay in there maybe if I take the
bishop
anything could happen they're hard to
know torrid I know wait does that happen
no it's a nice joke oh yeah that's a
little joke alright Bishop got me there
tricked me pretty good
then trick anybody all right I have we
played Bishop stars nope I don't think
we played Bishop stars d4 oh you're
you're the one to just try to fool me
with the bits off you want to do
push-ups do you want yours go for
sipping get pumped up get the blood
going dick just for free just some free
ones making all the f3 Banco is mighty
you don't know about it you don't know
what the blueprint I yeah baby
put your queen somewhere in second right
Tech something like I mean I play this
what's up
so literally when I play do I have to
play this I mean I want to like sack
nope I'm doing the show bro super show I
thought you were calling in and I'm like
find a way to sacrifice a queen to get
to anything I mean this queen sac just
isn't very interesting what if I what if
I'd let me do this and I'll just like
take that night or something like that
then it's a sacrifice like the Queen's
that's not even a sacrifice dude sex the
queen you gots to just anywhere yeah I
mean I get it or lose a queen what can
you do I just like you have to give it
up yeah that's that's the power they
picked a good time it was good time oh
gosh
that's just it's got worse but it's all
just gotta do it right - I did do it and
went straight to dancer it's great -
manse now all you gotta do is or doing
it for now you just come back it's
really hard to mount to come back when
you don't have a queen like having a
queen is I'd rather sack like both of my
rooks all right like what like maybe
somewhere what's happening Marius like
trying to get that other guy out you
never know you never know anything's
possible in the world just Bishop check
get special check and though pretty easy
to block no stop
the shipping literally you can bought no
I think attacking people are distracting
me with real work they got it because
out the only ones here open out the kids
[Music]
look at that King though Kings big
target anything's possible you believe
it it can happen
detective Queen alright anything spot
some simple threats anything's possible
simple threats for a simple man you know
it's an important message for everybody
out there you know if you dream it you
believe it anything's possible
mmm-hmm it's a pawn sure sure
they take a spot yeah look I'm gonna
push you might be up like a lot of
material your kings really ugly yeah
suppose Boop all right getting mated
here no you're not it's getting stuff
back it's giving a lot
didn't know you just didn't have Devon
okay all right
obviously there's no real you can check
didn't take your Brooke you take them of
this show what you gonna do fish up star
look for the bishop went for it the
bishop this man do it he's trying to
wind is hard trying to win I had to
sacrifice a queen like God real dude
he'd make a place I gave him a queen and
he's throwing oh the other guy yeah yeah
yeah okay great of this curry to my deep
mathematical calculation he's still up a
queen and a knight oh yeah sure yeah you
want to repeat donor a big job will take
a draw take a draw
cross that bad result against this
rosboroughs just don't want to risk
messing it up yeah what takes no guess a
bishop I guess the night will stay there
save your bishop he takes the bishop of
check but he's up time he's up
everything
take your time bishop start find some
good moves I just went somewhere I will
take with Frank wait a walk
[Music]
[Music]
hmm Miguel just keep on moving just keep
moving you know you can be moving you
keep the room in it anything's possible
[Music]
get down just keep going just keep going
you know ah I feel like you're gonna get
hit with disasters you know you just
keep moving you just keep going just
keep on keeping on can't let it get you
down just keep it moving
just keep moving that King just keep
moving it okay sure sure sure
time to resign get out a way time to
about to win this no inside that's a
pasta time - Rizzo knee okay setting up
a deep one move check we set up the one
move I can't even take the night all
right good game Bishop stars boom eight
six big comeback for the stream we won
the first four then we started to come
back we got up to eight and now again
it's like every four games we just
turkey does a pleasure my friends I wish
I wish insects help just a little bit
just a little bit all I'm gonna say
about the Queen sacrilege like wakey we
played him - we haven't played who
played a unicorn let's get you in a
party game unicorns going this is a
tough one so let's focus here this is
three to strive number three - so
take it ticket ticket f3 take it
the mighty f3 bank Oh I got the
blueprint he didn't even do it
no that's the big center but hopefully
Isaac's done a little bit of prep in
this line who do you think do you think
your daughter do you know maybe he's
he's prep the old yeah baby
oh he's so smart he took the Queen away
now you have to sack it oh if you traded
the Queens would get to sex something
else oh you got a Saget there's only one
sec Oh
Devastator oh that was so smart I was
thinking to myself if he moves the Queen
we have to sack our queen if you train
of Queens ever the saved us you can't
trade another baby you just get to play
Johnny Queen every game thank you mega
Blaziken
and once again helping the kids and do
it for the kids I know I got this easy
win who get I believe why did you wear
your queen don't I believe where's your
queen go you big fool don't eat it
never needed it you balloon don't need
it don't even want it under developer
stuff there it's so difficult so
difficult
this looks bad yeah it's not easy to
play in a minute it's really hard to
play just yeah I'm losing what in the
world it feels different it doesn't feel
good it doesn't feel right does it it
leaves a bad taste in your mouth I don't
like this at all
no you should stop doing that keep
giving these people Queens I didn't
really saw how hard it is I'll write to
you to corn no take your time buddy
try to find the moves el boy is a good
one that is a good move I'll get you
pretty good
mmm-hmm whoever gave me the right idea
all me baby all me nose all pretty much
all this guy ya know who needs that pond
dude or that rook take your time unicorn
buddy
oh no they had that one anyway that's no
a didn't matter we're just getting
worried
you guys win you said you just basically
would although we didn't win a game
after a sub that was we did we did we
did win a game after a sub so played you
haven't played you but casual and six
minutes get Mikey I'm still remember
yeah yeah yeah so he played all these
people so we'll just art in order yeah
sounds like it this one has no income in
its five minutes zero inaccuracies zero
blunders switch can't even pretend to
run anyone I know it's okay she cuts to
ten seconds there you know we have to
stay up on time that's kind of the deal
oh yeah I play that free but you play
the Bishop d2 variation lots of
understanding here lots of understanding
usually catch Isaac in his free time
prepping the Bishop d2 himself all the
time where does it go oh you must be
prepping the bishop mega Blaziken come
again at least this time I could
actually take it well take my queen for
absolutely free commit to the Monday for
our stream by mega very much blaze a kid
thank you very much for your generosity
today don't maybe he's run out okay big
good maybe maybe maybe he doesn't match
really gets to the decisive moment
hopefully
you wanna keep your money maybe it
belongs in your pocket and not at the
good kids at night gotta keep it pencils
just leveling it out we're gonna see
what happens it gets close what's
happening in like the last game like
mention nine nine or nine and a half to
tonight a half something like that I
mean people could just they get to
decide really oh yeah people want to
play a super easy opponent for the very
last one just to try to save it for
ourselves
oh yeah but very easy games honestly
everyone's been it like a superstar
today it's not confusing at all oh yeah
you need to understand the medicine
together between out there like super
yes Pete or we always got to be ready
for it
you're absolutely right oh so I got to
think about everything my whole entire
opening repertoire based on what has the
Queen attacking something that it's not
really gonna take I play the Berlin a
little bit more I got to get the Queen's
off we got a plate we got to just trade
the Queen's off it oh it's like ships I
lost unless but then you still might
well you still TAS act like a rook or a
piece or something would still be maybe
that's not ideal yeah probably just
getting like a rook it's fine I can get
two pieces for a queen you dandy I did
that could be a challenge though it
didn't go well I did do it it just
happened to naturally somehow fell out
of my hands what happened to the Queen
somebody donated a sub yes he once saw
equals a queen sack yes if you do it now
we got a second look it's candy as black
pawns eonni as white makes sense makes
sense
what do we even do here all right I'm
gonna put a lot of work in now all right
I can't handle this I can't handle this
bishop anymore okay it's just like gotta
get out of my life what you don't want
to trade us I know but I do want to
instinct than I am right but I didn't
I've literally to look sort of I can
play kh1 fresheners played King eh what
this guy no I don't you got no ideas
zero ideas zero and you're great at
beating 2,100 down to Queens yeah normal
normally the hardest part gave on my
life and beat this guy yesterday today
it's a little harder today it's a little
bit more difficult just get the fun
don't try that works all right you're
right and you're right well yeah the
same mom this is also the show where our
relationship kind of falls apart of why
don't we give it to you anymore
we went into the day considering each
other brothers why this might be the
Shantz enemy show you why are you still
talking to me
let's fight plan we still like that's
deep like as deep like like way but why
I'm not gonna say you had any chance
anyway but he's giving away the mate
well done
mega Blaziken big winner there mega
Blaziken coming through mm-hmm yet again
all right so you're in the seats let's
pick some is there you know that sirs no
no bouncers try to give ourselves a
chance and honest this is an honest
fight let's try to give ourselves a
chance here this is a good honest fight
all right here we go
p45 med f3 knight c6
I know it good commentator see they just
literally say the motifs being played
Bishop c4 Bishop c5 c3 d6 that's what
good commentators do we make youtube
videos too they just say literally the
moves being played that's the trick
listen they usually sit back rock out I
look that's part of it but sit back
crank up the jams simple threat first
simple min some a man like simple
threats or is it better to keep that
Queen so far away it will have to take a
turn so that we get to threaten
something and then take something that
might be the plan so keep that Queen
back yeah so now do we have the second
piece for the Queen
like I think we still do the Queen right
so put her where you can take something
so go attack that night and then hope
the knight doesn't move away okay that
works that works that way we at least
get a piece yeah it's cuz your Venus a
fire we'd have six you can play like 91
we have to give the Queen away switch
get out the way alright what's happening
here
checkmate anywhere in checkmates I think
you're think so far that's the best
queen sac we've had Queen can take your
night baby
where's your trick no it's there oh no
the Queen could take my Knights
oh no not Queen takes Knight no pull it
apart no he doesn't see it I hope he
1998 doesn't see he could take my knight
oh boy oh boy oh boy oh boy oh boy oh
boy huh alright guess I'll stop that one
Oh my Knights still hanging all the
night
hang in hang in it to any mouse slipped
that Queen who didn't take a night last
turn yeah boy they work I
I'll try another trick ah all right I
got any other tricks here 1,600 down
McQueen anything's possible in this life
anything's possible you believe it it
becomes reality anything's possible
message all the kids out there that
thing why did I not take that moving
very smart idea but anyway this is
coming in pieces coming in my attack I
played The Witcher 3 I did the the whole
original campaign I haven't done any of
the DLCs but yeah it looks awesome in
coming in coming getting in there
getting invigorating on through big pin
big pin anything's possible guys you
believe it it can happen anything is
possible that's good it's good which one
yes what are you gonna go yes oh gosh
anything's possible you guys anything's
possible
do you believe in unlikely hoods
anything's possible in life guys just
gotta believe me
teleports your other night says h5 still
open up were denied to h5 somehow here
yeah do anything it's possible
you believe that it can happen this way
if I do I do it if we see it who wears
the route I can't reversing it backwards
so I don't like it's possible you Oh
hyung one night not kim taek's night
tonight for that one anything but king
tonight
oh he's trying to do it he hasn't found
it yet keep trying next time you try it
might work King takes night maybe your
mouth slipping maybe it's not letting
you do it try it try harder
anything's possible boy least important
thing in my life is that fun is
important thing I really want to play
your mouth I don't know don't speed up
there a little bit 277 open files g7 to
g7 got it remove lip didn't work
no rook randomly active random Queen
attack one time I'm around 1500 USCF
this guy's like 1900 USCF we are hanging
in there we are hanging in and battling
battling for a comeback anything's
possible even a comeback here make a
make it a little trick little trick you
gonna fall for it
it's not a good trick it's not very high
trick did you do it great Mesa Blaziken
mega Blaziken you've you've put it all
the innocent is never tried
yeah I think probably is really
underrated so that does help the schwanz
team
oh he time is a-tickin time is a-tickin
when I sang him know now my night is
hanging
I don't know
random move hope he wasn't expecting it
no I would I would have tried Bishop
takes rook because in no no make it
Queen because there wasn't a for
whatever just I don't want to take that
huh what's 200 is a 200 cylinders it's
at two minutes oh no oh no oh no oh no
our plan of flagging down here oh no
that's that's our did you
somebody actually blend out the time who
even wanted to remember I'm so bad who
even remembered who even knew that was
an option I didn't even know way to look
up I didn't know what was happening oh
my god believable that was super high IQ
mate theory with the theories oh my gosh
how long was that who knows
impossible to know but what's the threat
like this feels like a threatening move
but it's not a loser
I might see if I lean a little bit
closer I just lean a little bit closer I
might understand the threat so let's see
what yeah I don't know losing this
losing the ideas here sort of fun idea
at this point but that two minutes two
minutes was a killer
that was pretty nose pretty crushing
really is really smart
that's what we're not accounting for we
you know next time we cover these
challenges we're gonna take it to the
let's count didn't check actually smart
them pretty well a pretty good one the
Queen know at one point that's my fault
still possible alright very hard
everything's possible everything is
possible you believe it you can do it
that's why after this game I'm flying to
the moon straight to the moon
[Music]
all right so far so good okay I'm still
hanging in you just keep picking up rush
goes so I got to also worry didn't read
now that so I also had to stay away up
on time because the a minute I think
they're gonna flag they can just get to
help so they can never flag if chats
like on it
Queen takes f6 Oh Queen takes f6 no not
Queen takes f6 let me think that that
please we missed it
oh no okay
focus me focus focus trucks a common
trick so come and just be patient
tricksters building weight still flags
we're up a time again
oh I have a fun shoot for my Pongo
oh no oh no Colin hanging mmm your chats
gonna do a better job of picking which
horses to bet on you know they bet on
the 1600 horse and he's throwing there
goes all your hopes and dreams shrugs do
it again who are the best e to it
whatever band camp game nine to eight
match point
oh boy I'm definitely gonna win
what's he know if there's nobody okay
come on
Oh three two whatever three two
whatever or foe let's do it buddy take
me you me and vinyl win you're going
down you know what and I'll even play
this dumb opening I'll give you a pawn a
gift for you our phonics free pawn buddy
you deserve it you deserve it Wow no
definitely definitely don't bet on this
one or phonics is totally gonna lose no
matter what so it's not worth your money
guys what's happening would actually do
it for the kids and donate all your
money that's the thing you know what
you're doing yeah baby it's a queen a
sec em like physically okay so here
right that's really sick I have to do
this well it's like it that's so much
sack dude laughter right that's so much
sack like you're sacking the Queen and
the rook oh good that's insane all right
you got you got us I was a pretty this
is pretty brutal
that's so much it's not very good
yeah we're gonna close us up a little
forethought out that just toss your
queen away I can't trick you try to
think and write anything
I mean well you know we're doing it for
the kids guys it's for the kids
oh gosh but kind of ruining my vibe here
I had a great man going yeah we that one
[ __ ] did you feel just the wind get
knocked out of your chest there I feel
like I just got punched in the gut
nope didn't want it super long castle
dang it
Kenan Castle was really banking on
super-long Castle just hopeful Duff wait
for zeroes yeah so it's written down
traditionally you're settled you've had
enough to eat no he's folded much done
enough of our yeah no checkmate
anything's possible anything's possible
once you get these pieces going anything
can happen you believe it it can turn
into reality guys anything's possible
switch don't you lose us this one yeah I
better really pick up the pace here
remember it hurts you more than it hurts
me if we got to do a four-hour stream on
Monday no dices that's just for three
hours Isaac will be gifting to the Chess
Club for his deal of of the children
one more easy 2000 back to the desk I'm
seriously reaching my limit for push-ups
today okay I need to not get made it
somehow recovery time before the next
game starts next game is the big one
next game is the big one so take your
time here anything's possible
[Music]
wait I'm already dead on it oh boy
no I'm already dead yeah nice move too
nice Oh for the kiss 9 to 9 9 to 19
Isaac is at the helm the guy who is
gonna get punished the most and I'm at
the home to pick up at so let's go all
right where's let's play pick up at sir
all right is there a petty bat sir she
Pat's there's some check I don't know I
don't know if you're about click all
right all right unknown I don't know
no it's questionable oh no this is an
encouraging time for anybody really like
400 maybe anybody anybody really moved
to pieces does anybody here play chess
with first time ever here this would be
an excellent time I have this a big go
focus you take it taking us Theory
making a theory that take and no taking
is a bad variation that's a good move
it's one of the good moves
they take your night you actually don't
take you play Queen to f6 anything
possible now they're on your Bishop
there's some threats so we know six all
right get that Queen off so we don't
have the second left hand is the Queen
if it's not possible we can't do it if
white is really smart it was really
smart
oh well is that kind of sac I don't
really
does that count as a sec yeah what what
does this sacrifice it's a trade you
have to take a pun and come in on Monday
you guys just gave me an extra day at
work all right all right you just gave
me an extra day at work I want you all
know that make up lies again thank you
again gifting you owe me a day off sorry
sir that's my annex possible and now
that you just got to believe okay if you
believe with all your heart
anything's possible c6 don't trade c6
don't trade no this doesn't matter can't
trade pawns don't matter no like only
thing that matters is the kids and
that's and it's sure the only matters
and it's worth four hours of your time
doing it for the kids when it for the
kids big celebrity in the house hello
big celebrity in the house
everybody's waiting to check out Jason
woolum and nagi air playing the people
coming up next after Isaac remarkably
comes back to achieve an Omega victory
not looking good this is not looking
good
probably eight five because probably I
mean what a clean before is checkmate so
you put us up it looks like Queen before
is checkmate got to stop it a five if
there's another checkmate then we lose
what you starting checkmate I saved you
yeah get stuff out
Oh ladybug gosh how do we don't get make
sure the sunroom all this I mean I blame
this is a mega Blaziken like mega
Blaziken did no no no please don't make
me do any more push-ups no time for
push-ups
please no more efficient still time to
do rekt us today you just know Roy does
I know I don't wanna have to go all the
way over to the camera again you don't
know these pieces can move right no the
King don't give Brock rock any more time
anything's possible
dang it we're losers dude
we're big sad music we don't even have
sad music I didn't think we could lose
you guys really came through holy cow
holy cow big thanks big thanks to mega
Blaziken
big thanks to go tricks and everybody
else farmer was in there with some
donations they're a bunch of hackers
dude whoever had that plus two minutes I
was a genius hook us down oh man that
was brilliant man that was good right
that was a good one again that was
brilliant it was a brilliant move so
alright that was a lot of fun I had a
lot of fun with all you guys it was
pleasure hanging out with you guys enjoy
today I'm not gonna say I was a big fan
of the push ups but that was a lot of
fun yeah we will do this again obviously
this is not necessarily a weekly thing
we will do the trance bro super show
again though we will see you on Monday
what time I guess we gotta do the show
again right I guess both heroes will do
the show for our extravaganza transform
your show so yeah let's start at noon
I'll go 12 to 4 cuz noon noon central
one day we'll put it up on the calendar
you'll see it after this hang tight
Jason woolum and Nikki will be playing
up next later in the afternoon we have
Talia all a part of Super Saturday so
stay tuned well done good victory guys
we will see you on Monday see you Monday